[Musique]
la sécurité oui mais pas à n'importe
quel prix et qu'au fond les terroristes
finissent par gagner c'est-à-dire si on
ne respecte plus le respect de nos
libertés alors nous ne serons plus des
démocraties et donc c'est cela ce que je
conteste et je demande au plan européen
de bien vouloir regarder la conformité
avec nos valeurs fondamental j'ai
plusieurs inquiétudes c'est que
l'autorité judiciaire ne soit pas la
gardienne des libertés comme notre
Constitution française le prévoit là
j'ai l'impression que le premier
ministre devient le deusEx Makina et
donc le risque de collecter en masse des
données sans contrôle est un risque que
je ne souhaite pas que mon pays court et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je demande
quel est le degré de conformité avec nos
traités fondamentaux notre jurisprudence
et notre équilibre constitutionnel